i had to strip down to next to nothing
grease out put a towel over the cut
section of bar off the window so it
wouldn't scratch my back and leave it
myself out
well sten wrench that up just another
little inch
probably strangling everybody had always
hated since childhood but just enough
for me to get out
[Music]
i learned many and terrible things about
the thai courts
that
virtually everybody is found guilty i
went to court
and was transferred to klong prem prison
that's the main bangkok prison sometimes
called bangkok hilton
is huge it contains
12 subprisons
over 8 000 people crammed in there
the first night you spend
jammed into a cell wearing chains
they're squashed around your ankles
with a c-ring
and a connecting chain
and then lectured to by one of the
trustees in the cell that he doesn't
tolerate pooing in the cell and
reluctantly let you take a pee in the
corner of the hole in the floor toilet
the foreigners section was nothing but a
broken collection of ruined people that
the wind had blown into a corner of
asia nobody in there was going anywhere
their sentences were usually
between
40 years to life
out of 40 years people would serve
30.
a policeman from australia visited to
say
how destroyed i was how
even if i survived 20 years here they'd
make sure that i faced some charges back
there i tore up all my court paperwork
and made sure that they didn't know that
my case was
a death case
and
so i didn't have chains on all the time
because from the moment i stepped into
that prison in bangkok escape was on my
mind
some days they let people walk out of
the building and go to a christian
church meeting
and with my own personal trusty
prisoner
harry
the chinese guy he
took me around and i looked at all the
bars and where the kit the foreigners
were
oh very heavy bars they didn't trust
foreigners you couldn't have a ground
floor cell if you were foreign three
floors up was the closest to the ground
you'd get they
foreigners just might try something well
a story some swiss guy did once but
nothing came with it
i wouldn't advise anybody
when it comes to escapes it's like
voting
escape early and escape often
because that's the best chance you'll
get
really
even though i'd done my very best to
find out where i was within the prison i
didn't know
i had the room and i had one to go with
me
the big viking sten
a standard drifted around asia for a few
years and ended up getting tangled up as
a courier with some group
i got a feeling i'll stand double
crossed them and i'd heard stories about
him uh
helping himself to the silverware places
he'd stayed around town but that didn't
matter
it's how people treat you when they're
with you that counts and in an escape
there's one thing for sure everybody is
alone
a few things happened at once towards
the end of my time there
firstly
i was told that my case would be brought
to an end i would be
found guilty as and within two weeks
sentenced to death
and the execution wasn't pretty
one thing it was certain it was by
machine gun the prisoner is tied to a
plank
and a machine gun that is welded to a
bench has three strings attached to it
three guards pull those strings
because
none of them can say yes it was my tug
of that string that ended this man's
life
maybe it's a buddhist consideration i
don't know
but they wouldn't we had the guilt
necessarily
i'd been told by the
my contact with the american embassy
that an example would be made of a
european a westerner soon
and i couldn't think of a better example
from their point of view than me
so when i knew that i had
perhaps two weeks left to go before
my case would end
i would be found guilty sentenced to
death another thing that pushed things
along
was that
i really was alone my viking friend
pulled out
why
a few weeks
towards august i think it was
two israelis were transferred from the
north in chiang mai the israelis that
had arrived from chiang mai had
put off
sten from coming with me on the escape
their legs looked like they
they were deformed twisted
broken and reset they looked like some
angry kid in mcdonald's that crushed up
the drinking straws and thrown them to
the ground they'd escaped from that
prison in chiang mai because it was an
easy lock-up
but they'd been ruthlessly hunted down
their picture was on every tuk-tuk
driver the police actually weren't
involved it was the prison guards
hunting them down
such was the shame of all of this
they went to their old friend the guest
house manager who milked them for their
remaining money turned them in
when they were arrested they were thrown
down in a dungeon somewhere in the
chiang mai prison
iron bars were used to shatter their
legs and big rocks thrown onto them
having served in the israeli army they
were made of reasonably stern stuff and
one dragged himself out from under the
rubble and nursed the other one back
with a bit of water
so by the time they arrived in bangkok
they were a bit brighter but wearing
elephant chains with these mangled legs
when stan the swede saw those big and
mighty though he be
he said to me i have nowhere to go on
release
i've been prompting him to get a
passport
i wouldn't know what to do
he was almost angry with me for building
this up he never really thought it was
going to happen
and i told him it's happening tonight
it was because the guard who usually
slept outside um
the grounds outside my window was not
there
turned off the light
waited
turned to sten who'd promised to help me
during the night and said
it's happening
without telling anybody i started
unpacking the cell
it had time
time to build
furniture which
could come apart and go back together as
a stepladder to the tall upper window
the only window in the cell
i put that together went into the shower
and broke apart
a poster that somebody had sent me
michael actually which had two tungsten
or hacksaw blades in the top and bottom
of the dowel rods holding the poster i
figured they wouldn't wreck it because
it had a vaguely religious nonsense
written
other tools i took out from
[Music]
a pocket knife to
a laser pen
flashlight other things that were hidden
around the cell
started to work on the the bars
now
i'd made a rough timing of what i
thought everything would take
but the first stroke
of that tungsten steel on these old bars
was like a
the worst violin player in town it
seemed to carry throughout the whole
building
so while sten worked on that slowly
grinding his way through i had my nose
glued to the cracks in the cell bar on
the sleeping guard
probably 60 feet down the way
he stirred a couple of times
itself stand to stop
but nobody passed it was after midnight
an hour later
the first bar is not even cut i went to
work on it myself dispensed with the oil
got through it
as it broke it sprang away from the rest
of the
set of bars and frame of that window
so old was the building that it had
twisted and the bars had been under
pressure so they were pushing against
each other
went to work on the second cut of the
first bar
and time's going on i hadn't accounted
for this
sten said look let's leave it for
tonight we'll go the next night
we couldn't
there was an indian guy in there mirage
who was very real for a mirage he he
would have been straight out there
thinking me out or would have led to an
accident or he would have done something
even as it was i had to persuade him to
be quiet on the night
i had to be quite cruel to him in a way
to frighten him
because when he started moaning a bit
loudly at the grief of being caught with
people escaping i'd lean down next to
him
and i got close to his ear
i said mirage
believe me
when i tell you the only reason the only
reason i don't kill you immediately
is that it would upset
my friends in the cell
but it won't upset me and i will if you
make another sound
he was quiet after that
and we went on
i don't think i would have but i had to
make it persuasive
i got through to halfway through the
second bar and it was three almost three
o'clock in the morning i couldn't wait
any longer
luckily
sten was had been working out with his
homemade weights of concrete and whatnot
he climbed up on the the frame and
grabbed that bar in a towel and rested
forward and gave me about six inches
clearance
that six inches would have to do
on the side of the wall there was a
bookshelf
it wasn't really it was a
building site plank
that we'd managed to persuade the guard
was going to become a bookshelf and in
fact was until it came off there slid
into the side of the bars and projected
out into the night air
it was held in place by a footstool that
twisted around to be a lot set of
locking pins that would hold that
that plank sideways poking out so that i
could climb along it and then get out
of that cell which was just the first
step
i took out six
i said no eight picture frames standard
pretended an interest in oil painting
which gave him a chance to put together
some very stout very stout frames to
hold the canvas these were in fact to be
the rungs of my ladder
i took out
from my bag 100 meters
of army boot webbing
the rope
it had actually served time as my bed
frame as well but that untangled well
enough i had to strip down to next to
nothing and grease out put a towel over
the cut section of
bar off the window so it wouldn't
scratch my back and leave it myself out
well sten wrench that up just another
little inch probably strangling
everybody had always hated since
childhood but just enough for me to get
out
and then i held onto the outside bar
and instantaneously
like some insect clinging to a window
i was no longer part of their world
i looked in on that cell as though i was
looking at strangers
i threw that army belt webbing over the
plank and slid to the ground i had
clever plans web sailing but that all
fell to pieces and i draw the skin off
my hands
flipped the rope off back down through
my hands as it spaghetti to the ground
and stan
slid back that plank into the cell so it
wouldn't be seen and said of course
send me a postcard
everybody thinking though i wouldn't
make it very far
i knew roughly where the guards were
yet there was another flaw in my plan i
timed it during the day
the world is a different place at night
completely different
everything takes longer
a window that a door that had been
secured i had to take out a nail the
nail took some pincers the nail made a
protest as it came out and squeaked even
though i didn't put oil on it but that
was taking time went past her old toilet
and cooking area had to freeze for a
minute while a guard got up to take some
water
drooling because i'm holding a torch in
my mouth as i'm trying to arrange these
picture frames into window struts had
gaffer tape from a
care package that was sent in
and cable ties made two very long
ladders i had a sea of walls to cover
and felt like i had no energy left
but knowing
what would happen
knowing never my death that's nothing
knowing that i would die slowly and
horribly
i went on
by around
4 30 perhaps five
o'clock i found my way to the outside
wall i'd known that from the
church meetings
but there was another problem
below the main and very
tall wall took more than twice the wall
of
the height of any prison i've ever seen
there was only a foot and a half of land
space
before that
was a a place we called mars bar creek
it was an inner moat there was actually
the sewer
so what go through the sewer carry my
letters through the soil but i couldn't
because they were full of barbed wire
and i would have got tangled up in them
here's the thing if i'd been with sten
if i'd been with anybody else
we would have argued about how to get
across mars bar creek
we would have
lost time we would have lost the
important time i wouldn't be here
i broke a bit of the
one of the long ladders off
put the ladder against on an angle got
over to the little tiny ledge anchored
that in used my bit of rope and levered
that ladder over there i was between two
guard towers
one i could see faint stirrings or
imagined i could what was the point
just go on
manage to level that ladder up against
the wall and get to the top which has
barbed wire and electricity and i could
see the faint glow of dawn as i looked
over that wall
that was encouragement too
i got myself over that top wall
by just going very slowly and not being
freaked out by those tingles that you
get through your clothing and your sweat
with when there's electrical wire
running past you that had knocked a
couple of people off years before i'd
heard so i knew what to expect
i used the last bit of army boot webbing
to make a rope to sail to the ground and
found myself before the 25 meter main
moat
and realized there wasn't time to go
across that plastic bag full of clothes
or not swimming or not
it would have been noisy it was so quiet
i had to go around
the one place i could walk that was the
front entrance because i realized i'd
gone to the side wall not the back
i had one thing that helped me well
perhaps too
i'd clean myself up with the last of the
water and put on some long car key pants
prisoners were not allowed to wear
anything but shorts and kaki which was
the color of the guard's uniform and i
put up
an umbrella a black pop-up umbrella from
the umbrella factory
and it was just raining enough
so that i had an excuse to put up that
umbrella because as i walked slowly
towards the front
crossing bridge at the front of the
prison this is where guards are arriving
for work and where their shops and
people are setting up for the day
i thought somebody looking down
must figure
maybe it's a guard coming in late but
one thing's for sure
escaping prisoners don't take the
trouble to bring an umbrella in case it
rains
and i got to the front and i even saw
because i'm peaking here
my own personal guard from building six
arriving for work
i don't know what it was i'm sure he
recognized the way i walked he thought
something wasn't right but i kept my
head down and crossed the
parkway to the six lane highway that
goes to the airport but i can't take
that yet
i climbed up in the pedestrian walkway
and turned around and looked at the
prison look back upon what
12 000 people two and a half years of my
life
the deaths the suffering in there
it felt like it had nothing to do with
me
and couldn't work out why they stayed
why they never wanted to come
where everybody else had failed and
where i'd seen escapes
fell before is what happens after you
get out
i climbed down i took two taxis because
i had an address when i arrived there
i broke open a
wooden key tag this key i had was
encased in wood in case i was caught and
then tortured for information about a
key i had i didn't want to have to
answer that one and you don't know what
you're going to say under torture do you
i opened the door to the apartment
went to the little toilet in the back
and then started feeling back behind the
mirror
and saying to myself david
you met
harry in prison a chinese friend in
there he was released and he's told you
that he's got a passport
that has to be stolen within the last
three weeks so that it's uh
it can be put on the computer and the
visa matches up that's had the visa put
in it that has the passenger arrival
card and is on the computer and he's
taken my old radio operator's license
photograph and had it transformed into
this new passport that's just been
stolen and that dear david is waiting
for you behind a toilet in an apartment
to which you just happen to have the key
is that likely
but i felt the cardboard edge of an
envelope
and then opened it up
i don't guess i would have cared what it
was in there but it was good enough and
i was back on my way to the airport
within minutes
and a fresh set of worries
because at the airport i'd given my
money away to the guys in the cell
they'd needed to protect themselves from
the worst of the guards actions
i had two atm cards i'm trying to decide
where to go i picked up a traveling bag
which was left in the long term luggage
office by another good friend
the importance of friends
put my atm card in pressed it up and it
it says
please contact your bank
[Music]
okay
the second one though paid out and i had
to work out where i could go with five
hundred dollars
not far
singapore in fact
bought myself a ticket hurry to the gate
because it's on a call
immigration officer at the desk
and at every stage i'm wondering where
this passport is going to fail because i
know it's going to fail harry couldn't
have known somebody who
had somebody at the airport who typed it
in but trust your chinese triad mafia
they know what they're doing
their word's good enough and after a bit
of a frown they tapped me through and i
was on the plane
delay taking off
but finally the most satisfying
sound of
the swamp
is doors to manual says the captain and
it's locked up and the air pressure
changes and you get into takeoff
position
and then land at singapore and i've had
an hour to think of the death penalty in
singapore and had an hour to look at
this passport the graininess of the
photograph as it's been transferred and
other sets of problems that might occur
have that my chinese friends taken the
trouble to put the pink ultraviolet ink
across the photograph edge and now it's
too long to worry but there i was
at singapore
i think the immigration man agreed with
me the photograph wasn't satisfactory
so he slid it under the ultraviolet
light
and i because it happened so often in my
life before that one moment before the
end and everything's all over because
singapore would have sent me straight
back never mind the fuss of extradition
handed it back to me i took two taxis to
an airport
went straight to the shop there bought a
pair of swimming trunks
dumped my bag in my room took the lift
to the top floor where there was a
swimming pool
dropped my towel
dived in the deep end swam to the other
end
my clean moat
lifted myself out stared across the
hills
in singapore
and moved on
that was it
did you ever find out what happened to
sten
sten the swede my viking on the night
he did he regret uh not leaving with me
perhaps he did but he stayed
he was sentenced to
50 years
served 12 of them before being
repatriated to sweden
was released
and lives happily as far as i know with
a new wife and some children
how about you when you look back on it
all do you
see your story
as a regretful episode or something that
shaped you
how do you think it's changed you in
terms of who you are today
it has certainly produced a person
my life has produced a person who has
a regular nightmare with a different
prison
every night extraordinarily
how they look so different every night
but there's always one
and as far as my waking life is
concerned
i think
would i be willing to
forgo all that i've seen and learned and
understood
for a quieter life
yes and no
but it does rig huge destruction and i
think this
in some ways it's a wasted life
if a person has the capacity to do
something
good or more interesting or
hell even helpful
that's a choice that is better made
because
the regrets of loss are so large
that
even though there are some things that
i've come to understand that
perhaps not many people have
a very high price was paid
how did it work in my case badly i made
as every conceivable mistake possible
i even
turned to the shoeshine boys on the
street
who managed to score me some pretty
rough edge but smokeable sort of hash